this year the nominees for Best
Supporting Actor include names that
could light up a marquee all by
themselves among them are two previous
Academy Award nominees and another who's
already won two Oscars this first award
of the evening may have been the most
difficult to decide the nominees are
Danny Aiello and do the right thing Dan
Aykroyd and Driving Miss Daisy
marlon brando in a driveway Martin
Landau in crimes and misdemeanors
Washington in glory
Denzel Washington
oh thank god I get to use this Oh 45
seconds right I want to thank the
Academy I'm gonna thank Ed's wick
Freddie feels who did a fantastic job
who made what I consider to be at least
one of the best five films of the year
I'd like to thank my friend and manager
Flo Allen fabulous Ed Lovato and Todd
Smith and George Freeman and God bless
you my mother I love you my beautiful
wife pauletta the kids my son said he
was going to make one out of these make
one of these out of clay for me now I
got the model for him I want to thank my
first agent the late Ruth Aronson who
believed in me
I'd also like to pay homage to the the
54th the black soldiers who helped to
make this country free
I thank God I thank you